hi I'm Libby
um I'm a software developer and a worker
owner at position development
and I currently work remotely from
Wheeling West Virginia do you have any
West Virginians in the audience
no
so that's cool and I was a kiss doll or
kaseke set system artist from 2001 to
2006.
so this here is a preview of a doll that
I made when I was in high school so over
20 years ago
um
and today I'm going to talk about what
the kasekai set system is who created it
and why
why I am trying to revive it and I'm
going to talk about my kiss viewer
smooch
so what is the kaseke set system
it is an open specification for creating
digital dress-up dolls
now I tend to get one of two responses
to that either wow I love those things I
used to play with those when I was a kid
um awesome or I get why
um why in the world does there need to
be a specification for that what's so
complicated about dress-up dolls why
would anyone make or use this
and the answer to that
um is in the history of Kiss
so
kiss was invented in 1991 by a person
calling themselves mio.h
on a Japanese bulletin board system so
this was pre-World Wide Web
the internet was really expensive really
slow
um but users were trying to create these
dress-up doll programs and share them
with each other
and while I don't have a lot of
information about the motivations Behind
These creators it makes sense that if
you separate out the program that is
used for viewing the dolls and the
actual assets for the dolls you can make
the files much much smaller and get be
more efficient right
um so there's a lot of um
components to kiss or a few important
components the first is the cell image
format so cells are named after
animation cells
and that's because they have a
transparent background just like an
animation cell
and they also have index color
and this is a custom image format that
was created just for Kiss
but you may have heard transparent
background index color and you might
think well why not just use a use GIF
that was invented in 1987 so it was
around
so why wouldn't you just use that
well
I can't again can't really know the
motivations but
um
I do know a couple of vantages that
cells have over our GIF and the first is
that along with cells we also have
another format which is the KCF palette
format
so a gif file carries around its own
palette so if you're not familiar with
how indexed images work it's kind of
like paint by number so we have a whole
list of all of the pixels in our image
and we can say
okay this first pixel is pixel number
one second pixel
um has color number two third pixel has
color number two and then we look each
of those colors up in the palette to
figure out how to render it
with a Cell It's the exact same thing
the only difference is that instead of
each cell having its own palette
these cells are sharing a palette and
that kind of gives you a little bit more
of that file size cost savings right you
could have your whole ordinate or a
whole wardrobe be coordinated right
they're sharing colors uh you don't have
to repeat that information with every
single file
the other neat thing about
KCF palettes is that it allows for
really easy palette swapping which is an
old video game trick where you make
something that looks like a new image
but it's just the same image with new
colors and all you have to do to for
that is change the palette file you
don't have to change any of the cells
so that's a really useful feature of KCF
the third important component of Kiss is
the configuration file so we have the
images we have the colors the
configuration file specifies pretty much
everything else so the positions that
the closer in
um what the color what the background
color is
um and anything else that is important
to display in the doll
and then
um
because kiss dolls had all these files
so we have all these cell files all the
palettes we have the configuration file
we need to bundle them up somehow
um and artists typically used lha
compression back then that's what was
popular in Japan
and
you may be familiar with it from
um the because it was really popular
with the Amigo computer system and
apparently it's also used a lot with
doom and Quake and I put this in here
before I knew that he was going to be
talking
it's kind of neat
um
so 1994 kiss had gotten popular enough
that a person called Kos wrote The Kiss
General specification which laid out all
the information that was had at the time
about how kiss Works
um what the file format should look like
and all that stuff
and
then in 1995 came F kiss which was the
Next Great Leap Forward in digital
digital uh dress-up dolls so fcus was
invented by an American artist named
Doug Sherman and a Japanese artist named
yav and they added um capability for
animation sound menus and all sorts of
other interactivity
so
let's see if I can show you what that
looks like
okay so
um who here knows uh ronma one half
for you guys it's an anime about this
this boy who um gets cursed
and um
now whenever he gets splashed by cold
water
um he becomes more much more feminine
and then when um his son and body gets
hit with
with hot water if I can figure out where
my mouse is
um it is lost but anyway he turns back
um
oh wait there it is
all right
so this has like a whole lot of effects
it's got the animation it's got the
interactivity it's got the sound
um so yeah that's that's fcus that's um
what they added there's also F kiss two
F kiss three F kids four two different
flavors of Executives five
um that were all added after this
um but this was kind of the first
edition
so
from 1995 to 2005 there was huge growth
in kiss and a lot of that was just like
Rising tide lifts every boat like
internet was getting more popular so
stuff on the internet got more popular
um and also at the same time anime was
getting more mainstream and people would
like go on to Alta Vista and search
Sailor Moon and they would find these
dolls of Sailor Moon and be like oh I
want to make those
and with that came
um at least a seeming change in
demographics we don't have any like
numbers or anything but you kind of can
kind of look at these dolls from like
1995 and earlier and they have like kind
of a certain theme
um which has definitely changed by late
2001 and I would say it's like it's kind
of like the fantasy of the hot girl on
the motorcycle uh to a fantasy of owning
a ton of clothes that are all really
cute
and that's just a generalization
obviously there were there were all
types of dolls in both um eras
so unfortunately kiss really started to
decline around 2006 2007.
um at least in the west so because kiss
became a lot harder to make
so um
that was mostly because
um new operating systems were coming out
people were upgrading their computers
and suddenly all the tools that all the
old tutorials were written for stopped
working
this new
um or the the later audience for kiss
was not as technical as the earlier
audience they could not figure out how
to make it work largely or they just
didn't want to have to bother because
there were all these other Alternatives
that were coming up that were like ways
to play a dress-up that didn't require
you to have this technical knowledge so
we had things like The Sims you could
make your you could dress up your little
doll and then you could play in a
virtual house with it
um we had IMVU which added social media
to your to your dress-up dolls
um and then there were like
browser-based dolls where you didn't
have to worry about installing something
on your your school computer
um and it was a lot easier to share the
dolls with your friends
so
because of all these changes English
speaking kiss making kind of died out by
2010 they're like maybe literally a
handful of dolls after that came out
after that
so if historical reasons explains why
kiss was invented and it explains why it
died out it doesn't really explain why
we should still care about kiss
people are still making these digital
dress-up dolls with other software then
why try to revive kiss at all
well
um for me the most obvious reason is
Nostalgia this is something that I
enjoyed making when I was a teenager
enjoyed playing with
um I consider my first publicly shared
coding project to be a kiss doll this is
one I made when I was like 16.
um
so
that's a big driver for me personally
but another reason is that I think these
dolls are important
um I think they're like
great snapshots of what internet culture
was like for this whole time span and a
lot of them have like interesting
documentation that are attached to them
they explain like the thought processes
behind like why did I choose the subject
matter why did I choose these clothes
what was it like to make this doll what
is the response I got to my previous
dolls and that is all like really
interesting stuff to have and I wouldn't
let people I want people to have more
access to it and be able to see it
plus some of these dolls are just I
think really beautiful
um this doll here is one of my favorites
um Nigel by Kid and Rick Kramer uh just
because like he's a really fun character
and people kind of did that stuff they
would like make up an original character
and just give him like ridiculous
amounts of colors
and and this character also had like
letters from his friends he had like
stuffed doll collection
um it was a doll within a doll
I think that's really neat
and kiss had a lot of unique features uh
so how many y'all have played with um
pickeru
yeah anybody use picker to make their
like Twitter icon or whatever
um there's there's like several tools
like that that are kind of like the most
popular present day dress-up dolls I
think
but they really have different strengths
and weaknesses compared to kiss
and I don't know of any platform that or
tool set that has the flexibility that
kiss has so
a neat thing about kiss is that
um
I forgot to show this this is like an
example of a very early doll from 1993.
um
so I can barely read it
is okay
so this is a a kiss doll supposedly
that
come on does that not work
oh it opened it up in my other window
sorry about that
okay so this is a target agency this was
an attempt at making Tamagotchi in kiss
um which is pretty impressive
so you can like click on one of these
eggs and then you get like a little
um a little Tamagotchi character
and then you can like give it a name so
I'm gonna name this one
um
Fran
laughs as far as I know there's no
keyboard input and kiss so they had to
do that
and yeah so now we've got like a bunch
of stats we can like try to like make
this guy hat oh he's sad I don't know
so I can try to make him happy by
brushing him I've got like food that I
can feed him so I can like give him some
milk
and some some of the Tamagotchis Lake
milk and some of them hate it and we'll
get mad at you
so like that's really impressive you
could not do that on paper let me tell
you that
um if you tried to make that in um
like there are some like that are a
little bit more like kiss but even those
don't even have a capability for
animation so you'd have to like be
making it from scratch in some game
making platform like a general purpose
one
which maybe is the right thing to do but
still
um
so
the fourth reason that
um kiss is cool is that it has an open
specification
uh-huh
oh shoot thank you
I should have thought before like
um has an open certification so a lot of
artists left for things like Sims which
don't have this as far as I know
um but kiss makes it is like has all the
information out there for you to make
your own viewers and tools so like for
me the question is like not like why
revive kiss but like why not like it's
all there
so
so let's talk about my viewer which is
smooch I started this in 2015 when I was
at the recourse Center
um what speech does is that a user can
upload a doll
and then on the back end we decompress
the lha archive read the configuration
file convert all the images to pngs
then we serve some Json representing the
configuration file and some HTML to the
front end
then on the front end we render the doll
and enable drag and drop in some special
effects
and then the user can play with the doll
so the back end is written in Haskell
do you have any haskellers in the
audience
one okay cool everybody else is going to
be totally lost but it's okay I'm going
to have slides available afterwards so
if you want to examine these in detail
you totally can it's also like the print
type is really tiny so sorry about that
um but
I'll try to like explain everything
verbally so um it's raining in Haskell
it's using a web framework called FN
um and which is an awesome web framework
if you are in high school you should try
it out
um
and so we have here a couple routes uh
for uploading Arcus files so we have
Route One
and another route
um
both of them do exactly the same thing
they're just two different ways of
uploading it all
when you upload the doll smidge first
checks to see if the doll's already
cached if somebody else has already
uploaded it and if not then it starts
processing the doll so
the hospital is known for being a
functional language but this app has a
lot of imperative code it's mostly like
do this do this do this do this so we
copy the file create the directory unzip
the file lowercase the files because I
could not figure out how to do case
insensitivity at all
um
but the most most interesting part is
when you get to create cells in Json and
that's where we actually start
um
parsing the configuration file and
getting all the cells out of it so for
parsing I'm using a
Library called parsec it's one of the
older parsing libraries and it uses
parser combinators which is just like
like the phrase sounds like you're
taking
um smaller parsers that can parse some
little bit of information and then
you're combining them into larger
parsers that can can parse whatever you
want
so um I made a this is a data type
for that kind of describes every
possible thing that somebody could put
in a configuration file it's every bit
of data that I might be able to pull out
of it
and
then we can write a parser that can get
all of the
the can read all those lines
um
and
whenever it looks at a line it's kind of
trying each of these parsers in order so
it's going to try to parse it as a cell
if it can't then it moves on to the next
thing
um and that's basically how the whole
thing works
so we'll kind of look at really quickly
at
parse a line in a second so you can kind
of see what that looks like
so
um personally something in general is a
great opportunity for test driven
development so this here is a sample
configuration that's in my test test
Suite right now
um that I basically pulled from the spec
I was like what does the specs say that
a configuration file should look like
so I wrote that up and then I could
write tests that said okay if if I parse
this into my Haskell type what should it
look like
and then I could
um once I had that all that to the spec
stuff done when I actually tried to load
real life kiss dolls every time I ran
into a problem I could write new tests
until
um
you probably can't even read this but
basically it's just adding more and more
junk like is there missing data are
there like weird extra characters are
people just like tagging ampersands onto
the end of random lines
um that were not in the spec and yet
other players played them so mine should
play them too I guess
so
here's an example of one of the CNF line
parsers
so most of the parsers start with
looking at the first character in the
line so a helpful thing that they did
when coming up with this configuration
file is they were like okay every line
is going to represent something
different
and we're going to kind of prefix each
line with what that what the thing is
like a signifier for what you're going
to get out of it so all the cell lines
start with this pound symbol so we know
how we're going to parse the rest of it
which is neat
um
you uh I I again I am going to share the
line the slides too if you want to look
at this in detail
um you can check those out later
so once I have a whole list of
um CNF lines
then I can like
process those into a type that is a
little more structured that I can turn
into Json so the list of CNF lines you
know it could have like any sort of
random data in it I don't know if it has
everything that I need and I don't know
if it has like maybe multiple like it
could it could be nothing but five
copies of the Border color you know and
it would technically be a list of CNF
lines
um but the CNF kiss data type kind of
says no you've got to have exactly one
description of the Border color you've
got to have the window size you've got
to have a list of cells
so
um
yeah and then we can take whatever value
we end up creating of that and and use a
library called ason to translate that
into Json
so once we have the configuration file
translated into Json
the next thing that we need is to
convert all the cells and pallets into
something that we can use on the front
end
and I originally thought that this was
going to be the very hardest part of
this project
but luckily I was still at weaker Center
when I was working on this and
um a person named Mark Dominus was a
resident at recursor at that time and he
volunteered to help me with
understanding the specs so
I don't know if you can read it but the
spec was to me absolutely indecipherable
because it was just saying stuff like
um LSB MSB
um had like
you know I was talking about bites and
bits and stuff that I had no clue about
at that time and he really helped me
understand what that stuff meant
um so I ended up making a c program that
could convert these cells into another
format called a portable bitmap
then we could take the portable MIT map
and just use a standard tool set from
netpbm and then that would translate
them into pngs and then I could just
show those in any browser
so that worked really great
but then a couple years later a person
called huggable monad which is an
incredible name
um approached me on on GitHub and was
like hey can I translate your um still
at a pnm program into Haskell so that
you don't have to like just shell out to
this script and I was like that would be
awesome
and um they actually wrote a whole bunch
of code to
um to use this Library called juicy
pixels
to read the cells in in Native Haskell
so let's look at how that works so
palette files are actually really really
easy
so um palette files are just a list of
colors basically it's just an array of
red green and blue colors
um
so you if we can just like read you know
what's the red value what's the blue
green value what's the blue value of
this color
and then stick it into an array we're
done
cell files are a little bit more
complicated but not much
so um to show you just how simple they
are
um I've pulled up one of them onto
onto a into a hex editor
so this is actually a cell that is a
drawing of Sailor Moon's cat Artemis
um
and you know like if you're looking at
it right now you're like that doesn't
look like anything
but
I can pull that oops
also oh no
we enjoyed her a little bit too long
okay here we go
if we pull this so it's the same size as
the actual cell
and scroll down
you can actually see the cat kind of in
in the image in the bites I mean these
are just bites
um so that's how exactly how decompress
this image format is
um
it is not hard to translate
I gotta remember
yeah
okay
so um so all you have to do is get the
width and height of the cell and then we
just look up each color number until we
have
um in in the corresponding palette
until we have an array of colors once we
have the width and the height and an
array of colors that's all we need to
make a PNG
using Juicy pixels
so that that that's the back end early
saw the interesting parts of it
um for the JavaScript
so for some reason in 2015 I was
determined to avoid using any libraries
I wanted to learn vanilla JavaScript
um and I wanted to like keep the project
simple I had this idea that I wanted it
to be easy to contribute to
don't ask me why I used Haskell then but
the front end could be easy to
contribute to
um and I kind of had this idea that
using a framework would kind of involve
more baggage for potential new
contributors
so at first the JavaScript was just one
long static JS file there was no web
hack nothing like that
um but eventually finally this year I I
converted it to es6 and started using
modules using parcel just to make it a
little bit easier to develop with
um adding some tests with milk and chai
but there's still no libraries it's
still just vanilla JavaScript
so um my first try at rendering the doll
I thought I could just like take all
these pngs
um stick them in image ties and just
like spit it out in the browser and then
tell the browser okay just like position
these in the place where the dolls said
they should be
and surprisingly that almost worked like
I could you could look at the page and
it would look just like it looked in the
um in the a real kiss viewer
the problem was when you actually tried
to use the drag and drop because the
browser didn't seem to understand that
if
um a trans if there's a transparent area
I expect to be able to kind of Click
through that transparent area at the
thing beneath it so like with this doll
um if she's got like a long sleeve shirt
underneath of the scarf try to click the
long sleeve shirt and it selects the
scarf instead because that is rendered
on top of the the other thing
so
um
yeah you'd have to click like way over
here
to like be able to click on the shirt
so the next thing I tried was using
canvas instead HTML5 PMs and at first it
was even worse because like
once you've drawn something on canvas
it's not like it there are separate
elements that the browser knows about
all it is is just like one image
so how can our JavaScript know what item
of clothing the user is clicking on and
what what should be dragged around
and the solution ended up being another
cool like Old School uh video game trick
and that's a ghost canvas which is also
a really cool name
so you assign a color to each item of
clothing or you know any item that you
want to want to be clicked on
you draw a second canvas
that colors each item each item with its
assigned color just entirely only the
transparent parts are not colored
then when the user clicks uh it the
JavaScript will look up the
corresponding pixel in the ghost canvas
and it will see what color
that pixel is
so if you click on the dark dark shirt
here it'll be like
um the color is dark blue
and then we can take that color and look
up what item was clicked
and that's how how the drag and drop
currently Works in smooch it works
amazing
and you can actually
um
let's see
I can actually open up
yeah there's the ghost canvas
and
that's a display none
and you can see it so you can go on
Stitch and like play around with this
and and see what what it looks like in
real life
but that's how it works
so
the um
the the latest thing that I've added to
smooch
is f kiss this is only F kiss one the
first version of f kiss
this is um event-based scripting
everything is an event or an action
s only happen when they're triggered by
events there are no variables no
conditionals it is a super simple
scripting language
and this here is a blink cycle for a
for adults so we'll be saving
pull it up
so it's for this doll so if you if you
watch watch your face you'll see her
blinking in a couple seconds There She
Goes
so um
so this code is
um is how she blinks so
basically when these events go off all
the actions that are inside them happen
so to start out with we we unmap that
means we hide
um a cell that is like her eyelids
we set a timer
um for 600 milliseconds or 6 000
milliseconds
then we
um when that timer goes off we show the
eyelids uh cell so it looks like she's
closing her eyes
then we set another timer
when that timer goes off we hide the the
eyelids again and set the first timer
again
so it's it's a loop without any actual
loops
and the way that this works in smooch is
that on the back end when we're
processing that configuration file we
just have a few more things that we can
parse out of that we have the events we
have the actions and then we have any
arguments that those events or actions
can take and there's really only three
there's it can be an object number it
can be some text or it can be a just a
number number
I probably could have gone in more fancy
with the types here and said like well
sometimes those numbers represent you
know milliseconds and sometimes they
represent timer numbers
but I decided not to because I'm lazy
so um we start out with with some fkas
and we end up with Json
then on the front end we're going to
take that Json and we're going to turn
it into executable JavaScript
and the way that we do that is that
we're going to go through each event in
the fkus one by one
and we're going to start out by looking
up that event in a sort of map from the
event names to some functions that say
here's how we're going to set up the
event and if you want to see all these
you can go I've got a link for the repo
in here
um but just trust me that's what they do
and uh when we once we've looked up like
here's a function that's how to set up
the event
then we're going to go through and we're
going to set up all the actions that
happen during that event
and actions are just functions
so to make an action go off we just call
the function so we have another map
that's from all the action names to what
happens when we call that action
so there's a map from unmapped to mooc
on map
which says okay
unmap always has an argument of what
needs to be unmapped whether it's a cell
or an object number
so we're going to find that object or
cell
and then we're going to call on map on
it
a tricky thing about JavaScript is that
if you just call like try to return a
method on a function like as if it's a
function it does not like that like
that's something that I thought would be
able to be able to do based on my
experience in functional languages
but since I'm doing this weird
combination of functional and object
oriented it's it's not happy
so what you have to do is you have to
call bind on the function that you're
returning and tell it what object that
you are calling that method on
so
um
that's how the actions work
then events are just JavaScript custom
events
so since we're just using JavaScript
events all we have to do is add an event
listener and then when that event is
dispatched
um we can have our actions happen
and it works just like anything else in
JavaScript
um to dispatch the event we just call
this dot dispatch event it's really easy
with with our custom event and we give
it a name
so that that that right there is like
how begin and initialize work are really
straightforward the the one that's
tricky ends up being timer
the action that sets a timer and I
originally thought I could just use set
timeout and be like okay set a timeout
for
um for 6 000 milliseconds
the problem is like Kiss is like keeping
track of the names of these timers and
whenever you make a new one it's like or
whenever you set a timer it's like
resetting the existing timer with that
number so it got complicated
um and it really looks like a mess at
this point and I don't really understand
it but
so like timers are definitely the
hardest part but
um
yeah fcus works at this point so at
least all the ones that that are
commonly all the events and actions that
are commonly used in sets
and I guess now it's just fcus2 that's
just three F because four that I have to
worry about
so
um
let's talk about like where is the kiss
going in the future I would really love
it if people started like more people
started making pistols again and that's
why I'm making smooch
um so some things I've thought about is
like
uh what if we added some support somehow
for pngs everybody knows how to make a
PNG
um everybody has tools to do it nobody
has tools to make cells
um and artists just expect the did
artists don't really know how to work
with index color so
that would add a lot of convenience
so that's something I've been thinking
about
the other thing is like how can we
encourage people to make tools and to
um make their tools like open source so
that everybody can work together to
maintain them and improve them
so I'm really trying to like there's
like maybe 10 of us who are making kiss
right now we've got like a little
Discord server let me know if you went
on the Discord server
um and I've been trying to like kind of
help people understand like uh yeah so
you can learn how to code please please
learn how to code see we can all work on
these tools together
um also I would love it if smooch could
have more contributors so if smooch
sounds fun and interesting to you I
would love to have you on the project
um please please talk with me after the
after the talk
so that's all I've got thanks so much
for coming to my talk
um you can find me at Libby
horrorcheck.com you can find my
workplace at positiondev.com
um smooches at smoochdolls.com for now
at least I really haven't productionized
it so who knows when it's going to crash
uh check it out while you still can
um
and then I have the GitHub for switch so
you should definitely check out the
speech GitHub
and and there's the slides right there
big thanks to Clockwork prince who is a
person from that aforementioned
um Crystal Discord who has helped me so
much with learning about kisses history
and William Miles he made the the kiss
viewer that I was showing uh
um uh Agency on
um that's like the only one that's
usable on Mac so I'm greatly indicted to
Liam miles for keeping that going
um so yeah thanks